in this video we will study about the
gluconeogenesis let's play this term
which will help us to remember about
this process just from the name the
world Group Co means glucose neo means
new and the word Genesis refers to the
production under normal circumstances
the carbohydrates are broken down in the
human body by various enzymes into
glucose but this is just a breakdown
under special circumstances substances
like fat amino acids pyruvate are
converted into glucose thus the
production of glucose from new sources
thus gluconeogenesis can be defined as a
synthesis of glucose from non
carbohydrate sources before beginning
make sure to support math simplified by
hitting the subscribe button on our
youtube channel we can also visit med
semi comm for a small donation maybe
share new flashcards written articles
suggestions and much more so let's talk
about the concept of gluconeogenesis in
a bit detail the average person consumes
food many times in a day which
ultimately gets converted into glucose
and this maintains a blood glucose
levels between 100 to 200 milligrams per
deciliter throughout the day the excess
of the glucose gets converted to
glycogen which is stored in a liver and
this is used later when the blood
glucose levels fall
another fasting state the blood glucose
levels start falling and excess of the
glycogen which is about hundred grams
gets converted into glucose which
maintains a blood glucose level but this
like Rajan reserved soon gets depleted
and the blood glucose levels start
falling but some tissues in the human
body like the nervous tissue and the red
blood cells can only utilize glucose as
a source of energy so substances like
fat amino acids and pyruvate get
converted into glucose by
gluconeogenesis which maintains the
blood glucose levels about 50 to 60
percent of the gluconeogenesis takes
place in the liver 40 percent of this
process takes place in the kidneys and
some minor amount of gluconeogenesis
also takes place in the intestines the
metabolic reaction involved in the
process of gluconeogenesis involved like
alice's Krebs cycle and sub burn the
reactions so it is very very important
to understand about the process of
glycolysis and Krebs cycle in detail so
before progressing any further make sure
to watch the videos on glycolysis and
Krebs cycle on our Channel
so we consume food in a lot of complex
carbohydrate forms throughout the day
which through our intestines gets
converted to glucose glucose is a six
carbon compound and if you have studied
a video on glycolysis you know that the
glucose is converted to two molecules of
pyruvate which is a three carbon
compound this happens through a series
of ten reactions known as glycolysis out
of this three reactions are irreversible
it is very important to understand the
significance of these three irreversible
reactions these reactions are catalyzed
by specific enzymes which are
upregulated only when the concentration
of glucose is high so that the excess of
glucose gets converted to pyruvate this
prevents excess concentration of blood
glucose but these three irreversible
reactions can be reversed using specific
enzymes which are upregulated only when
there is a deficiency of glucose in the
blood these reactions are upregulated
during special circumstances like
fasting during fasting this pathway can
run in complete opposite direction so
that the pyruvate gets converted to
glucose
other substances like propionate are
first converted to intermediates of
Krebs cycle which then get converted to
pyruvate and substances like lactate are
first converted to pyruvate directly
which converted to glucose later so here
is an overview about the process of
glycolysis glucose is converted to
glucose 6-phosphate by the enzyme
glucokinase the glucose 6-phosphate is
then isomerized to fructose 6-phosphate
then the enzyme phosphatase adds another
phosphate at the first position and
converts it into fructose 1 6
bisphosphate and through a series of
reversible reactions fructose 1 6
bisphosphate is converted to
phosphoenolpyruvate and 2 a last
irreversible reaction phosphoenol
pyruvate is converted to pyruvate by the
enzyme phosphofructokinase the first
reaction which is reversible and we have
to talk about is the conversion of
pyruvate back to phosphoenolpyruvate for
this pyruvate first traveled to the
mitochondria through specific carrier
proteins in the mitochondria pyruvate is
converted to oxaloacetate by the enzyme
pyruvate carboxylase the enzymes in the
green are the gluconeogenic enzymes
which are expressed during fasting in
this reaction carbon dioxide is used and
ATP is also used oxaloacetate is then
transferred back to the cytoplasm which
through the help of the enzyme
phosphoenolpyruvate carboxykinase gets
converted to phosphoenolpyruvate in this
reaction
GTP acts as the electron donor and
carbon dioxide is liberated back
phosphoenolpyruvate then is converted to
fructose 1 6 bisphosphate since these
reactions are reversible
the next is reversible reaction is the
conversion of fructose 1 6 bisphosphate
to fructose 6-phosphate this is brought
about by the enzyme practice 1 6
bisphosphate ace and the last
irreversible reaction is the conversion
of glucose 6-phosphate back to glucose
which is brought about by the enzyme
glucose-6-phosphatase phosphatases are
the enzymes which break the phosphate
bond
now other substances like propionate
lactate and glycerol also are converted
to glucose through specific pathways
let's first talk about propionate
propionate is first converted to
sectional co a and if you have watched
the video on krebs cycle you know that
extraction Alko a is an intermediate in
the Krebs cycle which gets converted to
oxaloacetate and then oxaloacetate is
converted to phosphoenolpyruvate
substance like lactate is converted
directly into pyruvate by the enzyme
lactate dehydrogenase and glycerol which
is derived to the part tissue it's first
converted to glycerol 3-phosphate which
is then converted dihydroxyacetone
phosphate and dihydroxyacetone phosphate
can be converted to fructose 1 6
bisphosphate 2 the reactions of
glycolysis so this was all about the
gluconeogenesis I hope you find this
video helpful make sure to subscribe us
on YouTube and like our page on Facebook
for all the latest updates